hello everybody this is gamespot I am
here with the incomparable my crystal I
like the objectives I collected during
these interviews Dec I like in comfort
that's nice and we are gonna play some
volume so you know what are you showing
me today so I'm showing you some levels
from volume this is kind of this is the
GDC demo so we're getting very close to
kind of a finished game now which is
exciting because we've been showing for
about a year so the improving it based
on everyone playing and this is this is
the GDC version freshly fixed after i
did some demos in the UK found some bugs
most of all god now um and yeah we're
going to be showing may be showing you a
few few levels but kind of hopefully get
an idea of the range of the game and
kind of all the one all of them but a
lot of the like mechanics and gadgets
environment interactions and enemy types
and all kinds of things because one
thing we've we've not shown a lot of the
depth of the game up to this point so
we're showing we're really focusing
right now on I'm just giving an idea of
how how big of a game you accidentally
made all your kind of will join make
something very small and concise and
then we just kept having ideas for
things that would be quite cool which
got a little out of hand so yeah I want
to show you some levels but actually I
want you to play something okay so I
load you up the level now now you are
stealth player yes i am so you get to
skip the easy levels oh boy oh so i'm
starting off with a level called out of
circulation which is really just the
pure kind of fun movement interaction
well gorgeous well thank you know i
should say this very good our team we
were responsible for that stuff I will
take credit for them as i always do it
event so what you want to do for this
one you move with a less thumbstick you
use the left trigger to go to cover you
can move around cover by pressing the
cross when you're at a corner and you've
never saw with squares to attract God's
your objective and even further ah the
objective is to collect all of the gems
in the lever now the advice i'll give
you with this one is it work your way
around romantic lockwise because i need
to we need to change layout this level
little bit because right now everyone
always goes to the right of the screen
and that's a very hard women you can't
do it but it's bitterly okay nah the
tree to capitalize I was new counselor
place here you're going to collect
James once you place all the germs the
exit to the level of poor balance your
buddy you know Alan etc I get it that's
right now we've got waist-high cover and
tool cover if you're behind waist-high
cover and you're not crouched into it
you will be saved I'm flicking rations
wheezes laughs d and you can see the bit
on the Beijing cones you get kind of
shadow when they're seeing / shortcut Oh
God okay but I pray thee physical you
get close to them you can usually get
yourself around pretty safely oh boy
that's cool you really fine and he's
gone so so yeah so you're absolutely
safe those fission cones are completely
honest okay you're never going to be if
you're you can be literally standing
next to them if you're not in the vision
tone you're fine we really wanted to
create this kind of almost soon you okay
yeah we would create this kind of super
self guy who you will view it you want
to i want you as you play the game to
get feel safer and safer in environments
and had work your way through those are
those diamonds are floating today so
check on so wait any move for one of
those who so your progress say something
yeah so we point we're quite liberal
with those to be honest because we want
to make sure we want to make sure that
people expect that you and your you push
of it because you know working and
getting cortisone and I feel like I'm
just just pitching the gate now but like
you there's no there's no like with luck
teijin so if you're a court you'll never
punish for very long and if you find
yourself in the position yet you think
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get killed here
or it's gone wrong you can just hold
down triangle to reset your level to the
last check on anyway so you can
instantly you're only ever a few seconds
away from having
here it's it's it's scary but it's so
that's not your phone you looked after
I'm yeah I'm thank you for the hint
about going counterclockwise like I've
watched so many players struggle going
on because it because I remember when
the level design has handed me this
level to kind of to review like they go
through quite a few iterations before
they share with me because they know I'm
a bit of a stickler so they they they
they kind of shows me this level and I
send them the message going it sounds
way too hard play all never deal with
matters I just got through what's going
to my teeth so let's the exit there okay
I can't get to that now you can go
clockwise but it's a bit trickier so get
better go yeah so basically I I didn't
realize you could go clockwise and they
messed me off and I tried to play it but
they told me why don't you go are you
gonna attempt to just read your not
retrack it but you can you know the room
now so you can stay you can leave a bit
file still stay a bit close to the
guards and you know he's not gonna turn
around its for you is there ever an
instance where like you could give you
if I like run up on him right now he
won't see you you could be you could be
literally at me to behind it because she
physically gone out to him yeah so it's
really about that kind of it's getting
up and I was a good challenge getting
the AI to be kind of you want stupid in
the kind of self games yeah we do as the
game goes on you're gonna you know is
going to be spaces where you're moving
your footsteps make sounds may be faster
and that perches angel they go boom
that's awesome i love that effect or
just like okay floats up so if you move
down with a left thumbstick there too
let's try crossed paths is a good one to
kind of give you an idea of kind of
quite a straightforward level but it
gives you an idea of some of the stuff
so if you press across there again we
load up so this is going to be
introducing you to some gadgets and some
context interactions things like that oh
ok ok so the is the controller oh you're
fine yeah if I'm sorry the way I'd say
so those white walls there are there
just like the usual low walls but if you
if you get our cover with them and press
X you can jump over heck yeah there the
gears walls so you can progress around
the level from those so that's all of
our contact and interaction the world we
have a lot of different kinds of objects
you can use you can
and yet simply just press that bones get
through now that he's flying so he's a
guy you can't sneak up on he's got a
360-degree vision of town she probably I
would step away from him for the time
being we're gonna come back to me we're
gonna grab a gadget and we're gonna use
that now there you can't get actually
over that wall because of a forceful on
the other sides you're going to work
your way around and the puzzles will and
see you ah so so here we have the first
guy to go and get past if you jump over
that wall again you're absolutely say so
this is a good place actually to realize
that you're quite safe as long as you're
not like right in front of him you're
fine but you have the whistle now the
whistles good because the whistle will
make him come round to investigate mmm
so if you move to the lady riders just
there and you and from that position you
whistle he's going to come round to the
right I was going to use the shortest
route and if you if you look jump it Oh
caught in the court in a spin oh it's
okay it's okay don't shoot me okay so if
you go around here um yeah so basically
there because because you actually got
our period where he's looking the other
way you literally can just run around
you don't have to stay in Quahog that's
one messed you up there so if you go
there whistle and then move and you want
to go there you go you freeze the
checkpoint now the next room yeah a
similar idea here but we're here you've
got he's gonna he can't get over the the
jumpable wolves so if you if you go over
to whether jump a wall is and you
whistle from there he's going to walk
all the way around which will give you
time to jump it and go now he's exactly
say gay so if you jump over that now
he's a sniper rap oh he's a sniper so
he'll be heat so he's got ridiculous
vision range you want to move yeah he's
a ridiculous vision range but he takes a
while to shoot you so he's he's never
really going to trip you up too badly
you should be like there you're going to
be seeing where you signed up as long as
you keep on the move quickly and get to
that middle space you're gonna be fine
I'm tilting it oh you're gonna stealth
it I'm just gonna completely sneak
around nice you're here I like it you
you're not impatient you're going for it
there you go fantastically done and you
can jump out there so homey so this is
the first gadget and this is actually a
much later gadget in the game but it's
cool so we put it in the demo oh this is
the masquerade so you pick this up now
you've got the bar on the top right
it's going to fill up what what the
masquerade lets you do is with the right
tree if you pull the right tree once
it's full you can upon the disguise of
the enemy which will be time limited so
maybe it will only work for a while then
it will run out what it allows you to do
is for example this guy on the right
here if you put the disguise on jump
over the little jump over the wall he's
going to ignore you well he's gonna he's
gonna watch him do it but he's gonna let
you pass so you want to put on your
disguise can't get that will come first
all right okay grab it grab it yeah
those vision codes are completely honest
and they're on the floor so there's like
you could literally stand a centimeter
away from that circle you're not gonna
be seen you're absolutely absolutely
safe so yeah chuckling who this guy's
and then you can run and he'll what I
suspicious but as long as you get behind
the wall before changing old crap no
you're all right you're right move they
go you're fine fine he can't jump over
you see you're safe Oh Oh crazy so you
got the gem there so if you want to grab
that now what you have here this force
field because you're on this side of it
now you can be activated so they're kind
of dominoes so any force fields they're
attached to will also deactivate she
gets they'll do an effect across there
oh no I got I got I didn't pay attention
okay you're fine you're fine you're on
alright so this guy same thing disguise
oh that would be how I do yeah so you
should be able just pause straight past
them there you go okay okay you're fine
I mean the ex paper and then you can
chill our way back up since yeah you're
safe there I actually have people who
will cope just wait there for a bit just
to just a chill safe safe area they know
where they are they're fine yes you want
to get fios last gem dry the top of
screen real cop this way yeah you find
you're fine you're using your disguise
runs out so if you just goes runs out
you're being watched then I'll after you
hema so it's a very time limited thing
because really that's the thing with
this game is it's meant to be kind of
it's a fast pace kind of puzzle game
we're not making we're not making hitman
we don't think we're making it man so
it's like it's it's a it's a it's a
everything kind of is pushing for all
Hellas if I'm animation bug because call
attention to that um yes so you need to
exit now yeah so everything's about kind
of getting you to play quickly that's
the reason we don't have like a limited
use on these these are all one timers so
you have you're never gonna run out of
gadgets use you always got but you
always have the gang is specific to that
level so it's kind of always about
trying to get you to use the cool stuff
because so many stealth games you I end
with the kind of I end with a bag full
of cool stuff I never used because I
found out how to pop them on the back of
the head button so yes that's the goal
so what should play now let's go a
little bit more complex with a gadget so
let's write office noise let's take you
there seven names I'm intrigued by the
story and a little I'm coming to get you
if there is this there's some stuff
there well yeah you don't hire Andy
Serkis and don't get him to say really
creepy scary stuff like that you know i
love it once we have him on board so
yeah so we've got the day by the bugle
in that room now there's a play sales
that day we need to insert bugle blew
explanation here that's an insight into
the world go deaf oh but what the bugle
basically is is this is this is a cool
gadget so with the right thumbstick you
can aim it and it's kind of like aiming
a pool game uh-huh so you can move
around and what you do is is you can
press the right trigger to launch it and
then you press the right trigger again
to make it go off anywhere on that path
you can make it go off and then make
some noise so it's a launch of a whistle
basically that's you can really this is
where it becomes where the game really
shows off that about
crowd control basically like that guards
there you've got an idea now how they
move so make it to you can get past
email being seen let's see okay oh I
know also I want him to turn around
maybe maybe they're gonna guys I do yes
so yeah you can launch it you can launch
it and you can set it off me those you
don't have to wait for it to go all
along its path you can pull that right
trigger again to make it go go early um
yeah which will get you around I want
him to just go away let's have a hello
there no so you can set it off with the
right people that right trigger second
time you can make you go boom company i
will come back it's a good ring maybe
well it will he follow that does it have
to be like in the geometry because he'll
he'll go an investigate so it'll get as
far as he can get to it so what you want
to do oh so he's not for the follow so
he's only gonna go towards the noise it
makes he's not following the actual
projectile so you want a launch it and
then set it off and that'll make a
splash of noise he can't see it until it
makes a noise so if you are and then tap
again oh yeah so it makes a noise race
that's too far away from him so you
probably want to aim at the bookcase go
across and Beth and then he'll go
graphic okay but when you get there
you're going to need to hide in this
cover very quickly grow to say oh and
then your recess you're fine i didn't
say goodbye too far did something about
to phone nice okay so i set it off yep
and then you want to get in there left
trigger to hug the wall there you go can
you sit out Oh
I dude nice is all the weight okay so
this guy Smith scholars gems oh he's
standing in their role in there I want
to be in there let's see I mean I could
maybe maybe can I hide here here you can
get pretty close though yeah pretty
close because as long as you as long as
you know in that vision cone you're fine
what if
genre turn around and then I can see
no nope nope stand there if anything
he's now doing a better job building
yeah let's see don't want you know I
came into another room if I was you I
would try and get him to because there's
always three rooms so if you can get him
to go into any of the other rooms that
will give you time to kind of duck in
and get into another room that he's not
in that's right so now if you get across
there nice and quickly oh no all right
and goodbye friend you're fine i missed
one okay you're gonna have to go that
way anyways get back out the level so
why don't I get him out out of there
somehow so you want to get him basically
further into this room he's in
essentially just so even if you gave
like over to the left there you just
need that moments what's not there you
go hey nice okay I'm just going to go
back
a little far away from him so that
circle shows their the range on the
noise beer in the right ballpark
okay see ya oh damn it oh I am really
really excited and overzealous there
that's okay okay let's try this again
okay see them out hey guys later okay I
your phone Coco book okay oh this is the
time excitable I swear this teleport
will tell you so that's how I water over
there but he's looking at he is that's a
puzzle is them oh that's all right go
anywhere I get bright back is that
coming very quickly go go go go go go Oh
God oh yeah you can have it use that low
cover next time you show all right wow
this is intense okay oh right yeah all
right thumbstick there I me hell yeah oh
yeah cool that's a really excited you
know how that wall there you go
occasions very cool that way guy
of course that's the exit all right so I
want him to go somewhere else
I'll be careful because if he oh you're
lucky oh and now around you're fine
you're fine you can run it it's worth
known as well like if they're seeing you
and you run in if you can get to the
exit in time doesn't matter if they're
chasing you you're fine ah cool we do
next so you're going into this um what
should we do next let's do fun you're
really you're liking it right way ok
let's do called causal relationships I
like the idea of sort of like the small
like the smaller puzzle where you have
to look really think hardly make I mean
that's it is that's what kind of the
structure this allows us to do is we're
not in service of like making you a roof
row believable space we're basically
making environments that fun puzzles so
I'm just a sharp and let you play the
song oh boy alright let's see ya so
until I July wanna help so you got the
epic jammer you're fine now you safe
you're safe there's no danger you're
fine this is a Gladstone really ok I
want this thing I like make it over
there because i'm close feel so find
another route set
I want that thing now you get to ride I
love the rolling over animation yeah
people like about those it's quite it's
one of the fun parts of making video
games is I got to spend an afternoon
basically sending sharing youtube videos
that's misleading he's not gonna see you
if you deactivate I really do find you
okay when I talk to level design as well
um I got to have like an afternoon
argument with VR the animator like what
kind of role we going to do like sharing
like videos of like those girls over
things so you can't don't oh and go that
way you can go through a ninja stop over
there and you'll be fine so don't worry
about him so this is the figments of
your gadget now this is sort of like
what you what you initially thought the
vehicle was this is basically this is a
decoy you the whole school so they're
going to shape they're gonna give chase
you don't go that way um yeah yeah
that's right so basically you launch him
and he'll keep running until he hits a
two block high wall basically and
they'll treat it like it's you I said
give chase and I'm trying to kill it so
if i send him over there about your
mouth yes go go go really okay i'm gonna
be like go after again oh god oh no okay
you're fine you're fine you're calling
you getting through this oh okay cool
okay so I need this but I can't get over
there you can't are you okay so this is
dude it's hanging out
guess endings of the Sega saw go after
him let's take us all yeah there you go
it's fine cool a boy
oh boy it's after deactivate this force
field where does it end right up that
but you can't get in there hmm you need
to work your way around these guys I'll
pass this guy basically oh there's an
opening over here did not sing with me
so this guy hmm can he go oh that's
right there's a couple ways of doing
this it's a bit tricky so I'm just going
to let you play a few time you see if
you can work it how's your gonna do
first time to embarrass me oh no damn it
okay all right okay to get him in the
corner or I can maybe get him oh well
that was dumb so one thing I'll give you
a chair I'll get right up on him I'll
give you tips so the one of the most
important things about the about the
figment is that it will it distributes
itself two strikes if it hits a two
block high wall it'll run straight
through a one-block I will so you can
kind of get it to do things they're not
technically physically possible and
games go places based on that he'll
he'll still react he'll still chase it
mmm so maybe that corner is not the best
idea so there's a couple ways I can give
you some tips if you are John me too now
don't work out you all right heads the
more time I will shush nice ah did you
know what's brilliant I've never seen
anyone use that solution oh no no way
it's he's seeing you out because the
four skills are translucence I can see
you through them um okay but but I had
the right idea we that's the interesting
thing is you didn't it didn't have no
hey hey you actually you actually did a
solution I've never seen anyone use
before which is exciting that's why i
love about Stealth now this there's two
very specific solutions that I see
people do normally and that's neither of
them I'll tell you that makes me happy
okay so this works that is all days of
working now what you want to do exactly
is hiding that cover let him do his
thing and come back yeah so the two ways
I've seen it done before is you can get
in to go up to that corner and because
they'll always turn it in the shortest
route you can actually kind of stay on
the right hand side of him as he moves
and that works the other options came to
run up the screen and then from cover
launch one to the left which also so
I've never seen someone doing that's not
efficiently before that's actually
legitimately awesome it just so I like
cut right it felt right if all right
yeah like Thomas was alone i love the
domino effect leading on this that's
lost on so like Thomas with alone that
was the frustration for me was that
there is kind of in the other one
solution to any of the puzzles and I
really wanted to make a game where where
stuff like that could happen where I
could be surprised I know it sounds like
I'm pretending that I'm surprised now
because I sounds like I'm using it as a
sales technique is genuinely true I guys
genuine the first time seeing some idea
that way awesome I'm glad to him hey
guys vented I now have three solutions
that puzzle I know just gonna sneak by
yeah well done cool okay um so what
should we do now I'm trying to think now
cuz you're getting through these just
fun okay so you want to press X against
go oh very house cool ok so this is the
mute so one of the biggest bits of
feedback we got when we took it to
advances why is there no run got some
big why the run run but the problem is
we can't add a run button to the entire
game is on sleeping with Ralph the
puzzles prison of the timings so what
we've done is we've made a the mute
which is a gadget which does two things
one it silences your footsteps which
means noisy floorboards which these
white squares you're seeing that would
normally Oh are usually jumping ahead
will you won't make a noise when you go
over them and to arm yeah you move a lot
faster cuz you're now he's gonna self an
alarm this is this is this is so what we
do because we're we're big on this a big
pile this game is level and so we
wouldn't make stuff is we want to be
allow people to make smarter guards if
they want to so the way we do that is
through environmental objects so we put
into the world alarm so once there are
alarms in a level you can make level
with our loans but you can make level
with alarms they'll start working
together and saying
four lions and calling in reinforcements
things like that so you want to be
careful about so boys level if you're
seeing their ass yeah there is there's a
their outcomes so you can get through
there by Vice hugging the cover and
using them you to make your footstep
silence so when you go over this floor
board he's not going to come looking so
if you that's right okay but these guys
you can just run right past with the
with it enabled they go and go yeah cool
go hug that wall and make it on go for
and get all those gems anyway I'll see
you because you're you're behind the
wall and there's no floor board so fine
just don't let go that left trigger
you're giving you need it and the alarms
ever get bad that's a locker to the
slide there you can always hide in the
locker oh really I will let you out
UConn you can't make a stealth game
without Walker's you can I did it's not
just about does he want the rules are
fast enough if they see you go into it
won't work and they'll show you through
the door and Oh thinking you can trick
them so it's not a gal jail free card
but as long as you as well as you go in
without them seeing you you're fine so
here you can just give in to follow that
mutant run yeah Mego course Wow very
close one foot in the diagonal so when I
said that I vision cones don't lie they
kind of lie a little bit just to keep
you out of them so they're a bit bigger
they look a bit bigger than they
actually are um but yeah cool so you
could just run right behind him again
with the with the mute on as long as you
don't make a noise be fine so go and
then go I would spell will we ran out
but you're fine now that one that one's
not near enough anyone they can hear is
here fine huh see you're fine you're
fine ok now I'm turning it that little
gem on the wall that's not Jam us the
alarm so yeah I'd that by yourself
you're gonna work your way for you to
this checkpoint and you're gonna be fine
there you go heck yes what's this that's
an oddity says another new guy that's
why I won't show you this one last cuz
you get two for the price of one gadgets
in this one is the art of you so when
you pick up a gadget replaces the oddity
the oddity is a shining cube which the
most exciting thing any enemy
the game has ever seen when it's all you
do is you could place that in the
environment and they'll just stand and
stare at it for a set period of time
also they will not hear any noises while
that's happening so here if you if you
stick an oddity in that picture frame
that's going to work to keep them
distracted because they're just going to
stick around and you're really a walk
behind them it doesn't have to be
exactly in the picture frame you waiting
for their general area that's right so
leave that there they're going to turn
but unfortunately oh they're too far out
she won't you want to stay back you're
going to bump into him sure oh yeah yeah
I got cocky I got you going okay your
cookie all right I see you you want to
out the right moment this is that there
is much too long as possible but you got
the idea i love that you can put a shiny
object in a room and they're like hey
yeah and actually their voice that
they're the voice over there they do
just say I all shiny and stuff like that
they'll get the comm obsessed with it
hey area okay I was wanting a blessing
that's right now boom they go perfect
and now you're fine to just from the run
past and they've got those time as this
you know exactly when they're going to
come out of them nice I'm right now this
last guy this guy's interesting because
so if you r it just run through there
he's going to turn around and see you
have six the noise you're making but
this is where you can even if you
actually stay in cover he's gonna hear
the noise and still come around and
start looking at you're going to be in
trouble but this is where this is where
like this is where you can actually use
on characters knowing where you are to
catch them so you can put if you put an
obviously on that wall next to you
basically somewhere that he's going to
see any might not see that explain that
wall all right wait and launch know what
you do don't run so if you if you stick
one so that this wall but once it's
recharged ticket so this will rain from
here that's right he exactly and then
what you want to do is want to crouch
into that wall and then move along that
wall crouched and the others on this
noble and by doing that you're going to
make a noise he's going to turn to find
you he's going to kind of set snares
just run out he's not gonna hear you
that's awesome so that's that's kind of
that's the depth that you can get from
it that you can actually intentionally
have been noticed at certain times in
order to be seen so now you switch back
to the mute because you can use that
which means you can just
but if you run out he will self an alarm
and you'll have I think you should it's
fun just ran I would just put those
along and just run off the exit go go go
go that's right now that checkpoint will
work now he's gonna go he's gonna get
his body's I would just make keep moving
keep moving keep moving there you go
you're fine you're fine go behind do it
you're doing it you are no point it's
right that's fine Hamilton which are
trying safety locations Eve you've still
gained some stuff this is exciting right
cool I know you carry on out um maybe a
bit more stealthy now I've never again
never seen anyone get that far actually
before they go kill them well you always
get killed but you can use the
checkpoints so that's the other things
the checkpoints are really forgiving so
you benefit you can benefit greatly from
foremost I guess again it's about being
straightforward don't run you are a few
options there you've got quite a limited
time on the run so um there's a few ways
of doing this you can tempt him out of
the room one way that's quite easy as if
you can get him to see you and then you
can hide from him he's going to run off
to the alarm to set it off oh but that
will just leave him leave this room
clear for you so if you can get away now
so so maybe if you get seen and then
jump behind cover and move around cover
so you can't see you so if I'd like if
he sees me and I immediately go down he
won't he'll come round but as long as
you keep moving behind cover like if you
if you get seen in going cover left
trigger and now so every time that
happens is a reset so as long as you
move quite quickly okay that's a hard
way I shouldn't told you hard way dude
but the easy way to do it is you can
whistle outside so if you just whistle
there yeah I know like literally outside
in the room if you can basically you
basically can get him so so lip trigger
run to your left run out of the room
wait now get into his vision home so you
can see you and now run with your new oh
sorry I'm sure it's all done for him
basically if you can get seen he's going
to run to an alarm which is going to
leave this whole area clear for you so
you kind of want to tempt him out and
then and then get away okay and then
when he's off doing the alarm you can
you want to gaze at okay beige / saving
oh wait come on come back come back hey
guy run oh no foster nearly nearly this
one's a bit tricky this one's crazy I
love it okay gonna whistle and I'm gonna
go over here I want to stay in his
vision cone right that's right run run
good so up run there you go now get in
that locker ahaha I know your things
when i recharge you need to get back
over now go go go go go go go go go go
to the exit he's game is along he's
gonna bring all his friends and but your
honor kegs you're gonna have been gone
by then can I will be long gone yes'm
awesome we did it we did it we did it
you did it I did it you guys it but we
did it but then you you also did it we
got it collectively it's all good well
thank you very much for showing us
volume and this is coming out this soon
this year soon this year so we get it
this year awesome thank you no worries